saw you on the set of Rocket Man in
England how did it turn out and how was
it what what are your expectations cuz
everybody's are very high mine are
really high as well I mean Tyler Jason
is outstanding and I can't wait people
to see I think Dexter Fletcher and his
element directing this and it's gonna be
different and colorful and moving and
exciting and fun what was it like doing
a show where you slept with your boss
strange strange but Helios most
outstanding generous actress I could
ever kind of hope to work with so it was
it was a joy every day you know you kind
of got to mix soap opera and action show
so was that is that what really
attracted you to it what is it about the
role that made you say I love this and I
want to take a bite of it and fans have
reacted I think it's to do with the kind
of moral ambiguity of all the characters
everyone's in degrees or no one's
definitively good or bad and and that
changes during the show some people are
good go bad bad go good and I think
that's kind of what really made me
interested in it because that gives us
so much to play with so you get
nominated what is the first reaction cuz
I heard it was magic what was your first
reaction when you're like hey I just got
nominated for a Golden Globe what was
that reaction disbelief something I'm
still writing with that really what was
I mean you're just like no there's a
mistake here there must be a mistake
that's what it felt like but it had to
be I mean then there had to be like a
lap around the house or something crazy
I was a walking had to go back to work
and it was a bit of a nightmare because
I was trying to I'm trying to do
something quite serious and I just was
pumping with adrenaline and like what
Wow can you tell us anything about a
next season and we're talking about it
we're gonna see what happens over the
coming year
I think the character needs a little
break you know you think he had quite a
tough couple of months the show so we'll
see what happens but really you're gonna
take it there's gonna be an extended
pause in between we're gonna see I think
there's lots of conversations happening
now so it's up to the brilliant mind of
Jed mercurial and so we'll see well the
whole James way you said you're not
gonna be James Bond username no way
right no I didn't say that Oh would you
like
it's very fast ring to be involved in
that conversation and there's some films
we made so who knows how Harbin division
so maybe
[Music]